Ich bin Lehroffizier für Kampfschwimmen-
und tauchen beim österreichischen Bundesheer
und ich würde jetzt gerne einige Sachen erklären,
zur Rettungsaktion der Kinder in der Höhle in Thailand.
Diese Rettungsaktion hat einige Schwierigkeiten
aus taucherischer Sicht.
Und da können wir vom Bundesheer auch
ein paar Fachexpertisen dazu abgeben.
Zunächst einmal muss man berücksichtigen,
dass die Kinder
jetzt nahezu drei Wochen
extremen psychischen Stress ausgesetzt waren.
Sie sind körperlich sehr geschwächt
bzw geschwächt gewesen.
Und die medizinische Komponente,
sprich der fallende
Sauerstoffgehalt in der Höhle,
hat sein Zusätzliches getan.
Zu den Umständen, dass sie drei Wochen
einer Feuchtigkeit ausgesetzt waren,
können wir aus Erfahrung sagen,
zb dem Dschungelkampf
den wir gelegentlich durchführen,
dass sich die Haut sehr sehr aufweicht
und diese natürliche Schutzfunktion verliert,
wodurch Pilze, Viren und Bakterien
sehr sehr leicht eindringen können.
Das heißt, diese Grundschwächung haben die Kinder von Haus aus jetzt schon.
Zusätzlich kommt,
dass die Bergungsaktion aus der Höhle
in Abschnitten tauchend
erfolgen muss,
was für die Konfiguration der Retter und der Rettungstaucher
eine besondere Herausforderung stellt,
weil die Höhlenabschnitte nur durch eine Person,
und selbst dort, nicht mit vollem
Equipment durchtaucht werden können.
Dieses muss vorher abgelegt, und vor sich
hergeschoben oder nachgezogen werden.
Die Rettungsaktion der Kinder erfolgte mittels einer sogenannten Vollgesichtsmaske.
Wir haben hier selbst eine vor Ort, die wir heute erproben.
Bitte Aufsetzen
Der Vorteil von solchen Vollgesichtsmasken ist jener,
dass sie, im Falle dieser Kinder,
in Panikreaktionen nicht abgenommen oder nur sehr schwer abgenommen werden können.
Zusätzlich wurden
die Kinder leicht sediert, sprich
mit Beruhigungsmitteln behandelt, dass sie diese Rettungsaktion,
die durch die beiden Retter vorne und hinten durchgeführt wird,
kaum oder minimalem Stress ausgesetzt sind und das Ganze sehr ruhig vonstattengehen kann.
Fertig zum Tauchgang?
Wassern!
Der Kamerad mit der Vollgesichtsmaske,
wird jetzt unter Wasser, im trüben Wasser
der alten Werft Korneuburg,
seine Ausrüstungskonfiguration überprüfen.
Für die heutige Rettungsaktion der Kinder in Thailand,
wünschen wir von den Bundestauchern, und das gesamte Bundesheer, gutes Gelingen.